how much
how much do you [ __ ] with cryptocurrency
you know i've dabbled in it here and
there and i got lucky and i bought some
i don't really like talking about it
because it bothers me that i own it
because i feel like i made free money
and i don't really care for it and when
i talk about it people get excited and
that bothers me
because it takes credit away from me so
i rather just let not even talk about
that
yeah because a lot of people listen to
it love it and it's like uh yeah i know
most definitely
but if you it's like stumbling on a
diamond ring you know
the floor i mean i i own some and i've
made a few dollars
but that doesn't determine who i am it's
just like
it's just like buying a car and finding
like i said a rolex in the in
in the middle i don't really i don't
respect anything that
that um that i didn't earn yeah
that was just luck what do you think
about uh
what do you think about the future of it
do you think there's do you think
potentially in like the next
10 maybe 20 years it could be something
that's legitimate that replaces the
financial
well system we have now i'll give you my
my point of view on crypto like bitcoin
i think there's 21 million bitcoins
yeah and i don't think there's going to
be any more generated
and i think the people have value in
bitcoin
a cause it's manipulated very heavily
and b
it's the fear of the u.s currency if you
look at this pandemic
we've already created eight trillion
dollars of nothing
yeah it's insane so i think our debt was
23 trillion previous now today we create
another eight so a third
of our world of our overall debt
in a year in a year yeah so people look
at crypto
as a hedge against
whatever else they're doing yeah that's
just the way i look at it like i hedge a
lot of things
but i think kryptos cool but if they
outlaw
crypto where you can't use it
it'll probably take a big dip and now
the irs is getting heavily involved if
you spend it you got to pay taxes on it
so i don't think it's going to be
i don't think it's going to go up as
fast as people are predicting
i mean it's hedging it's hovering around
55 to 60 000 at its peak
even though last year around this time
was about 4 000.
it might generate you know higher and
higher and higher yields but i mean it's
just
i own it but i don't really care to talk
about it because it doesn't make me who
i am and i it bothers me even owning it
well it's just interesting i mean it's
interesting because a lot of people some
people
like will buy and just hold it forever
like like me i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm doing with it i have a little bit of
money in it and i just kind of like sit
there and watch it
and when it dips it dips but i don't
like but i don't take money out when it
gets up
or buy more when it goes down or i do
when it goes down i do buy more
but when it goes up i don't i don't sell
it because i'm like well maybe it'll
keep going up
yeah or maybe it's maybe it's smarter
when it goes up a little bit to pull it
out
all of it out and then when it goes down
put it all back in i don't know yeah so
how i play it is once it hits a certain
number i target i sell it all
and then when it dips i buy it back okay
because i've already made a lot of money
just moving whatever i have
but once again it's like a hobby for me
it's like i'm driving out of red it's
like playing fantasy football yeah
yeah kind of sorta but you know and it's
a lot easier than real estate or
baseball cards or used or vintage cards
or diamonds or watches
because you're buying and selling in
seconds yeah
you know for sure what about nfts you
we talked about you know it's funny when
we mentioned that and i'm like wow this
is pretty amazing how people are just
buying
pictures of nothing i personally don't
understand it
means neither i don't think anybody does
i do see the value in it
because you have a lot of people today
who don't know how to interact with
people
and they live in a box yeah so they'll
have a thousand facebook friends that
have like two or three real friends
and if they walk somewhere their head is
down on the floor and they don't know
anyone
and the unfortunate reality is i think
that's what the world's becoming
see like i i interact with thousands of
people because that's what i like to do
you're a real estate guy
that's what real estate guys do though
that's true but i don't really consider
that a real estate person because i only
deal with the same people every single
day
and when i meet new people i just try to
throw them on one of them other guys
because unless they want to sell me
something because real estate
is basically you don't really need money
to make money in real estate
what you need in real estate is either a
a buyer or b
us a product what other kind of
businesses are you in
well i dabble in anything that makes
money you know what i mean if i like
look yesterday a friend of mine hit me
up
that he's uh he's a realtor he's a good
friend of mine he's actually
selling a property of mine for like four
million dollars and he hit me with this
eureka coin he said brian look at this
eureka coin
it was a dollar ninety billion talk a
little bit closer to them it was a
dollar and yeah you can pull it to you
yeah it was a dollar
ninety and i think the last night that
he hit me up at about 2 p.m yesterday
and the last i checked about an hour ago
was at 5 and 50 cents
really yeah look i don't even heard of
eureka coin neither did i
well 99 of the things today i've never
heard of
see that's why you know i jump in and
out you know
and then i'll play the wave and you know
i'll day trade and i'll make 70 80
transactions in an hour due to the fact
that you never go broke on a profit so
if you can make your little
in and out money just do it right
because i don't feel comfortable with
any stock
unless when you look at the balance
sheet their assets
are greater than their debt like
like macy's stock last year i think it
dropped to like five bucks
when you looked at their um their
balance sheet their building in
manhattan alone was worth more
than their stock plus their debt so i
bought a lot of that
how do you find their balance sheet well
you know any stock broker anybody knows
about stocks we show you how to work
that
it's really not that interesting but
it's a common common sense you can like
go online or something and like
just talk to a stock guy hey look what
do you think about this what do you
think about
but like the stock game is really not my
hustle i just don't find any
pleasure in doing buying something
that's intangible i like to actually
feel and look and smell the problem yeah
that's what a lot of real estate guys do
they're like oh i want to drive you
around and show you my buildings you
know right they get they get like a high
off of off of like driving around and
saying like look i own this piece of
land i own this giant building
there's like something to that well the
reason being is because you already know
the worth you already see it when you're
dealing with stocks
you got millions of dollars riding on
somebody else's knowledge or somebody
else's fear
because stocks are mostly news emotions
yeah it's just an emotional play you
know i mean it's hard
it's hard to control that when you when
you're a guy that's been doing business
and you've come from nothing
you have a lot of insecurities and the
biggest insecurity that i've noticed
with the thousands of people that i've
dealt with
is not knowing the future and when
you're dealing with something that's
intangible you don't know the future but
when you look at other people who've
come from money
and they make it easily they just they
don't really have fear because they
don't know what bad is
you know what i mean it's like let me
give you an example let's pretend that
your father was worth a hundred million
dollars
and you lived in a skyrise and he had um
bentley coupes and
phantoms and you know that's all you
know you go to
you're sheltered in your life and then
he throws you out in the middle of the
road gives you a million dollars here
and then
you're driving a uh e-class ben you
think you're doing horrible
but those people have never starved
they've never ate tomato sandwiches on
five-day-old bread
right so it's hard to respect that
hustle
you know what i mean so when when you
come from nothing you see
the value of anything you see the value
of one night stay in a motel
you see the value of getting to the
hotel at 601 p.m
a.m so you can stay an extra day you see
value in different things
you see a value in buying getting a used
car license and buying a car
and using it for free and reselling it
at the auction next week after
you detailed it made 500 bucks basically
on
a floor plan so you see different
aspects of life
when you go to other countries and you
see how people live then you come back
and say wow you know what
nobody in the united states should ever
complain because you
were born in greatness because you
already have a major head start
why do you think people from other
countries come here within three four
years they own businesses houses
meanwhile you have a lot of people in
this country all they want to do is cry
and their net worth is negative because
they don't understand what bad is
so if you once you understand what that
is
you'll realize that no matter what
you're gonna make it
as long as you're steady you know what i
mean
[Laughter]